[Música]
boa tarde a todos
o curso vai falar é uma coisa normal
ao contrário todos os outros jogadores
sou uma pessoa normal uma vida normal
sempre fui subindo a escada que o
verdadeiramente cria para criar com woz
coisa é que isso foi a minha vida porque
foi possível ser assim a minha vida
o grande desafio que se nos coloca
colocar toda a gente que hoje têm entre
15 e 18 anos em portugal é que esta que
vai ser a vossa vida
a lógica da escada com grau até a outra
será outro mudou radicalmente muito nós
hoje já o que vimos sobre a robótica e
aquilo que ainda vão ouvir tornou
impossível esta vida de escada e tornou
absolutamente fundamental esta nova
geometria em que o espaço vai rolar pra
cima pra baixo eo grande desafio vai ser
cada um voz construir o vosso caminho da
minha vida normal começou como a vossa
no ensino básico
acaba no ano ea primeira grande decisão
humanidades ciências ou arte arte tem
dificuldade com as mãos
tenha muito maus resultados e ver
especialmente possuía tudo errado
economia e ciências tem duas grandes
dificuldades teoria do mesmo duas
possibilidades era física e matemática
e foi com letras e no fundado pela
primeira vez um oval que não correu como
era suposto que teve um professor dois
tipos nas chamadas jornalismo relações
públicas têm essa particularidade a
primeira que não era português coisa
impensável era chileno ea segunda é que
não tinha matéria não tinha os testes
não tenham currículo não tínhamos
manuais e durante dois anos o que
fizemos coisas tomem foi o teatro ir ao
cinema
o edu
foi abrirmos um mundo que nenhum nós
conhecia na nossa vida de escadas
fui à coluna a cinemateca o quarteto a
gulbenkian
é uma quantidade sítios que nossas cada
virtual
passávamos por lá pouco scolaria acabou
acabou o secundário e pedir para sua
cirurgia era o que eu verdadeiramente
gostava mas se um dia não servir para
nada podia ir para antropologia cultural
uma coisa estranha que tenha lido um
livro mas novamente não servia para nada
e fiz o que as pessoas da minha geração
faziam escolher um curso que serve para
servir para alguma coisa vindo de letras
não havia dúvidas era direito a
ingressar no curso irá equipar mil base
escolar e foram uma cec um sacrifício
o curso superior nem se fala aos 20
diante horas sentado no auditório ouvido
um livro que nunca mais acabavam o
emprestou muito relativo
mas lá aguenta aí é que os cinco anos
com todas as pessoas que dão um passo na
escada e daí o paciente
o paço inteira aguentar 12 anos de
escolaridade mais cinco da universidade
ir para professar um pacote tenha tirado
um curso para um curso de direito claro
fui para o lado e escada perpetuou do
grafiteiro é muito alto
era um dos advogados médicos engenheiros
em função do curso que ambos tirados e
mais cedo ou mais tarde
entrávamos para forma estava eu no meu
escritório de advogados quando assumir
um enorme desafio uma promoção mesmo e
no escritório disseram vamos te pagar um
curso na universidade água mas no verão
durante três semanas a estudar com
advogados todo mundo e isto era numa
altura em que o estrangeiro era uma
miragem poucos nós lá tinha estado a
rolar iríamos e daí comigo mas o meu
amigo tiago em árvore
assim como o professor chileno comecei a
ver outras coisas nos estados unidos
aconteceu mesmo
e conseguiu ler outros livros
nada a ver com direito nessa aí vai o
que é o que a classe passou em frente e
nas bibliotecas e ler livros sobre
educação e isso é que começou a fazer
sentir vivo e estou junto trouxe um
problema enorme
é que sendo uma pessoa normal com uma
vida normal feito vaso que o solário um
curso superior que servia para alguma
coisa está a fazer aquilo que era
esperado com esse curso superior em vir
do do gado para a forma de consumir
menos competitivo conseguem pensar
verdadeiramente por alguma coisa
conseguem passar por ideias todas
aquelas leituras e quanto mais
conversava com as pessoas mais cheia da
escada da vida mais entrava no mundo das
idéias e de repente e de repente vimos
em algo que poucos dá me levado o que
fizeram comigo todo este percurso
fizeram foi de repente tudo mudou tudo
estava em aberto era possível
já não sabia qual era o passo seguinte
só sabia que gostava de idéias e aquelas
idéias sobre educação em pensavam e era
isso que eu queria dedicar à minha vida
e tive a sorte de conseguir arranjar uma
forma do hm pagar para eu vender idéias
e defender as idéias em que acredito
mas isso foi muito racional e foi
manchete nacional com o mundo em que eu
não ache era o mundo 1.0 no mundo é que
eu não ache não havia internet no mundo
em que o mesquinho inscrevemos cartas
escrevi aos meus amigos das caldas o de
évora
escrevi a carta durava uma semana a
chegar e depois uma semana havia
resposta imune não conseguia trocar três
cartas porque os meus amigos como
respondeu mais assim lamenta
quando saíamos à noite combinávamos um
sentindo uma hora e quando estávamos lá
as provas e quando passado maior ainda
não tenha percebido iam embora e nem há
dois dias quando chegava à segunda fase
e voltar vamos estar juntos na escola no
sabíamos o que teria acontecido essa
pessoa
os por fóruns estavam presos à parede e
quando alguém falava dizia o rodrigo
está
não está hoje quando eu chegar como iga
e quando eu eventualmente escava casa
envolve a chamada na escola os trabalhos
eram feitos à mão e o melhor que nós
tínhamos e teve muita sorte é que a
minha casa havia uma enciclopédia luso
como brasileira são 23 luz iguais a este
todavia imensa as coisas que não estavam
nos livros da escola estadual mundo 1.0
era o mundo da escada era o mundo
enviado espera um carro topo de gama
temos dois canais e era os dois o preto
e branco e às 11 da noite acabavam com o
hino nacional
neste mundo um ponto 0 12% da minha
geração e pós secundário
imaginem que esta sala era geração das
pessoas com 15 anos só a primeira fila é
que põe se escudarem e só 5 105 é que
acabavam de licenciatura e dentre todos
os licenciados ao longo dos anos foram
licenciados estavam na vida ativa apenas
3 por cento não tinham emprego
hoje todos toda a sala está no
secundário três vezes nas três primeiras
filas vão pôr ensino superior ies traz
desafios enormes
naquela altura um vôo nova iorque
colonos que foi um valor que em contrair
sérios custava dois mil e seiscentos
euros
hoje os cursos preço de hoje pois custa
400 euros na universidade éramos todos
portugueses ou pessoas que tenham vindo
dos dos palop
toda a gente falava português livros em
português e havia uma vez em quando e os
três já e fazer um semestre e que nós
achávamos que eram os lucros não servia
para nada que vai ao estrangeiro fazer o
que só de férias
vocês fato vivem no mundo que não tem
nada a ver com isto o vosso mundo 4.0
com os avanços brutais que temos na
genética na urgência artificial robótica
na tecnologia
vocês hoje tem no golfe mais primeiro de
acesso à informação de tratamento da
informação do que tenham estados
inteiros quando eu tinha acelerado neste
mundo 4.0 trouxe desafios brutais e não
é só os carros saem condutor mesmo
naquilo que nós tipicamente tínhamos
garantia da saída da faculdade querer
trabalhar como consultores financeiros
ou como jornalistas mesmo está em crise
este é dar dois anos em 2016 10 mil
relativos jogos de beisebol dos estados
unidos foram fight na imprensa escrita
foram feitas para uma árvore por
favoritos nenhuma intervenção humana 10
mil jogos
um estudo uma agência financeira da
bomba que provei que daqui a 20 anos 90
e 900 decisões de investimento sejam
feitas por máquinas
isso significa todos aqueles que não vão
tirar o curso já está 1 e desses 80% vão
ser consultores financeiros
é dúvida não é só gostam disto é dúvida
não é se isso não vai existir
a grande questão é como é que vamos
viver neste mundo 4.0 como é que vamos
viver neste mundo ou não é seguro feito
o ensino secundário ingressado na
licenciatura foi que eu vá ter um
emprego e uma vida até a forma o meu
mundo 1.0 morreu de vez esse mundo em
que escolhemos direito advogado ensina
médico e engenharia engenharia filosofia
professor já morreu
acabar o secundário se tudo correr bem
vamos ao ensino superior
e o resto está tudo em aberto isto é um
enorme desafio e eu gostava de deixar
hoje isso é uma certeza é um desafio
fabuloso é novo é completamente
diferente mas apps também fascinante
o curso superior não serve pra nada
um curso superior é uma base para vocês
construíram um curso superior na
universidade num politécnico no site mas
é uma base uma plataforma de
desenvolvimento humano a partir do qual
vocês vão decidir quais são os pacientes
e esse espaço índio consegue nos postar
é que seja uma aposta clara naquilo que
é fundamental muito mais uma aposta
clara aquilo que muitos bits e bytes o
computador não vai nunca sei que é um
ser humano é emoção
a relação à noção de justiça anunciar um
cuidado com o próximo
isso é profundamente humano e são
esqueçam os valores da humanidade levar
um tempo valor transacionado no futuro
e aqui há quatro conselhos profissionais
pensar no mundo da educação e do esporte
momento porque infelizmente as nossas
escolas a vossa escola é tão parecida
com a minha escola
provavelmente vamos ter problemas de
adaptação mas ao que vocês podem fazer
primeiro o edu ler desalmadamente sejam
das artes ciências e humanidades leão
desalmadamente tudo o que conseguiu em
tudo que os nervosos e não são tweets de
120 palavras eller mesmo é perceber é
treinar este músico que é igual a
qualquer outro músico vimos o ar sua
carreira na bicicleta este músico também
precisa trair e não tem que ser um
treinador incrível mas custa leão tudo
aquilo que passar pelas mãos impressas
de button button com os colegas sejam
exigentes no debate exigente na
argumentação não é eu acho eu penso não
é eu vi no google e um livro e button
button nelson mandela um dos homens teve
um impacto brutal no mundo em que
vivemos
dos 40 anos que esteve preso na
autobiografia diz que teve o tempo todo
a discutir e debater com seus mesmos
doentes e também dava pra se discutiram
discutir o que é que vai ser a áfrica do
sul quando nós saímos daqui muito foram
esses anos de reflexão de novato
permitiram sair uma pessoa melhor forma
de sua forte capacidade de facto
transformar seu país aprendeu às pressas
ea expressão oral da comunicação em
público mas é também a expressão
artística
aprendam a contactar com o outro
novas formas de expressão da pintura
avança é do corpo hídrico edson
a expressão é máquina não vai conseguir
bater e conheçam abra os horizontes não
afunilar não olhem pra pulga do cão já
mais tarde os empresários conheçam
diferente outras áreas são gatos e
impressas pela ciência são de ciências
entre essas duas modalidades são da arte
circense sem pressa nessa cima tudo abra
os horizontes
no meu mundo no mundo 1.0 um ponto de
ouro estava lá em cima das duas normais
classe média básico e secundário
licenciatura emprego forma no vosso
mundo 4.0 e isto é fantástico
há imensos fotos de ouro há imensos
posto sol competirá a cada um de vós
encontrar o caminho e construir o
caminho para lá chegar
e esta é a definição que eu mais gosto
de educação ea definição não só
esperamos que a escola nos ajuda mas
cada um de vocês ganhem está sendo
cuidado educar-se e adquirir uma nova
perspectiva sobre as coisas conseguir
deixar se enfronhar na realidade e ser
lá com olhar de frente força na posição
do outro e deixar que o mundo muda a
nossa volta
nós temos uma nova perspectiva sobre ela
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]